il faut que je fais un petit peu mieux
forcément si je commence comme ça on va
pas y arriver alors attendez
je sais c'est ce qu'on appellera le
cannage de dernière minute comment est
ce que vous allez aujourd'hui est-ce que
ça va bien est ce que tout va bien moi
ça va pas travail merci d'avoir demandé
alors aujourd'hui on se parle de quoi ça
c'est là c'est sur la table regarder que
c'est alors c'est écrit comme ça le poke
au mk2 pro mais vous allez me dire
monsieur gros le pourquoi de quatre
poteaux n'a parlé longtemps qu est-ce
qui fait tu déconnes et oui mais non ça
c'est le pot cohen quatre pros 4g et oui
je vous avais parlé du modèle 5 g au
mois de novembre me semble-t-il l'année
dernière alors pourquoi est ce que tu
nous parles d'un smartphone dont tu nous
as déjà pas dans une autre version
achevée les questions les réponses avait
buzzé je fais des petits boulots en même
temps et bien tout simplement parce que
même si ce smartphone a le même nom ce
n'est pas le même smartphone processeurs
différents il ya des choses qui changent
peu qu on pourrait dire ça comme ça aime
bien brouiller les pistes aime bien
sortir des tonnes de smartphones ils ont
déjà beaucoup de références qu'en plus
il est décliné entre la 4g de la 500 en
tout cas ça ils le font dans l'entrée
milieu de gamme pour être là pour tout
le monde à tous les prix site vous
conquérir de vous convaincre et puis de
brouiller un petit peu de noyon prend
les smartphones on les mélange vous
évader smartphones voilà on a foutu un
peu le bordel mais en attendant ils ont
plein de références et ça c'est
intéressant alors qu'est ce qu'on va
faire ici bien on essaie de décrypter un
peu ça essayer de comprendre voir ce qui
se passe est-ce que ce poème quatre pros
4g et non pas 5 g est intéressant alors
bien évidemment on va pas pouvoir faire
la 5g avec on s'en doutera mais
peut-être que vous vous n'avez pas prix
d'abonnement 5g plus qu'un abonnement 4g
vous convient parfaitement bien
peut-être est-il fait pour ça la
question et on se pose maintenant non
[Musique]
alors pour passer un peu l'histoire
rapidement lie à la boîte lyall
smartphone là on a même le bloc de
charger un peu tout ouvert je suis comme
ça je prends la bresse avant de parler
du smartphone regarder très rapidement
ce cas dans la boîte parce que vous
allez voir humainement mais y'a pas
grand chose vous allez donc ouvrir une
boîte jaune ça c'est du proco paf paf
paf on tourne pour fait ce petit jeu là
on va avoir le smartphone qui va être
normalement planqué ici voyez
sympathique où sort de là mon petit
lapin ici on a quoi eh bien vous avez
votre câble de chargement qui va venir
se brancher ici en usb à votre côté vous
avez l'usb c'est parce que oui en
dessous vous avez une prise en usb c'est
regarder hop là c'est extrêmement
pratique ça marche bien c'est simple ok
et voilà on a fait le tour merci
beaucoup au revoir à demain alors y'a
pas d'écouteurs parce que la loi
française oblige pas à mettre des
écouteurs de biche plus en tout cas
depuis début de cette année à mettre des
écouteurs on préfère que on met moins
d'électronique moins de produits qu'on
pourrait potentiellement avoir en double
chez nous plutôt que voilà bref c'est
une idée en tout cas ils ont fait ce
choix là je peux vous montrer rapidement
scadd danse ça vous botte et vous allez
voir que papa prendre grand-chose dans
une petite coque transparente si on le
souhaite on va voir les livrets de
garantie et compagnies prennent
évidemment le petit pic pic pour ouvrir
le tiroir de cartes sim à moi j'appelle
ça un pic pic voilà je trouve ça mignon
et sympathique qu'elles n'ont voulu
donner d'ailleurs vous à votre public ça
c'est mon pic pic vous c'est quoi le don
de vous donner sa ouvert le tiroir de
karting je pense que c'est un nom je
préférais plus que sa plus jolie voilà
c'est simplement ridicule de saint pée
alors regardez le smartphone il a un
petit effet miroir il prend des traces
de doigts bon ok rien de caisse un passé
je voulais montrer aux jo qui l'a
beaucoup x4 progemes bien ces espèces de
gros modules qu'ils ont positionné
larzac c'est pas extrêmement discret
mais c'est un peu différent et beaucoup
sale type pourquoi pas on va qu'on a
trois caméras 1 2 3 on les a là on va
qui est lié à ses écrits 6e juste écrire
sur sa structure en rien aux hommes qui
flashait de là on voit qu'on est les
caméras de 64 mégapixels mais ça on en
parle dans quelques instants la marque
est écrit ci a poco en dessous qu'est-ce
qu'on a mises à part les traces de
doigts peut pas grand chose le petit
normes ce qui est écrit ici sur le côté
on va retrouver votre bouton de volume
votre bouton qui font office de
directeur d'empreintes digitales pour
déverrouiller très rapidement et ça ça
marche c'est cool ensuite absolument
rien dessous et bien je voulais montrer
de la recharge en usb c'est le petit
micro le haut parleur pour venir écouter
parce que ça on parlera monde en parle
et c'est un peu dommage de l'autre côté
vous avez votre tiroir de cartes sim à
le regarder c'est là où je vais utiliser
pic-pic ben ouais faut bien qu'ils ne
savaient quelque chose d'atypique alors
je rachetais qui va nous montrer un truc
qui est très pratique et ben oui faut
bien qu'ils savaient les choses se
brouillent le pic pic il va nous montrer
que l'eau que vous l'utilisez et que
vous ouvrez ça eh bien vous avez quoi
qui apparaît vous avez double carte sim
plus une extension de mémoire carte
microsd donc ça c'est plutôt bien
d'avoir ce trio des fois il ya un choix
entre doubienne aux cimes hunan hocine
+4 microsd ici vous avez les trois alors
on peut augmenter jusqu'à 1 tera au
niveau du stockage c'est très très très
pratique fois plus là on ramène pique
d'être cotées sur le dessus qu'est ce
qu'on a et bien on a une prise jack on
le voit pour bien brancher un casque n'a
dû à erez ici directement aux filières
why not on va voir un autre part alors
en tout cas semble-t-il même chose allez
petit rouleau par là je sens que le sont
bien plus de d'ici là vous avez de
l'infrarouge et puis le micro pour la
réduction bruit un très très grand
classique un petit chat sur la photo
sinon en termes de prison mancunien paul
l'orge me ça combien on fait le tour
assez facilement il est plutôt bien
alors le poids c'est quoi
179,5 g comme je vous le dis il se
déverrouille rapidement et puis après
vous avez un bel écran alors un écran
avec une dalle de combien je vous
l'écris si mon papier est ce que tu as
appris par coeur c'est du 6 43 pouces
résolution full hd plus c'est-à-dire
2400 par 1080 pixels alors l'intéressé
sait qu'on a un écran amoled donc aux
led c'est donc dire que lorsqu'on
applique sa noirceur pixels et un second
dire que si on veut venir économiser de
l'énergie on va dans l'écran et on passe
antenne sombre lorsque temps thèmes
sombres tout ce qui est noir s'étaient
pas donc on vient consommer moins et ça
c'est bon pour la batterie de votre
smartphone c'est bon pour la planète
c'est bon pour vous et merci beaucoup au
revoir à main donc ça c'est pratique
alors ici on va avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans alors
attention regardez vous le voyez là par
défaut il vous le met en 60 hertz ça
permettra de consommer un peu moins si
vous le poussez en 90 ans vous allez
venir consommer un point est plus que
vous allez gagner en fluidité bon je
vous passe très rapidement dessus parce
que c'est un truc qu'on connaît qu'on
connaissait depuis longtemps vous avez
également un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 180 m alors c'est quoi cette
histoire ça ça veut juste dire que
lorsque vous allez venir toucher votre
écran ça va être beaucoup plus rapide
que si vous en aviez un petit peu moins
comprendre un peu l'histoire il ya que
lorsque je viens jouer un jeu et bien
j'aurais eu une réaction un peu plus
rapide entre le moment où j'ai appuyé
sur le bouton en amont l'action se fait
outre air où l'action est envoyé ça
c'est intéressant par megal et quelques
microsecondes par rapport à un autre
joueur à savoir que sur le modèle 5 je
vous ai présenté l'année dernière vous
avez un taux d'échantillonnage tactique
de 240 air donc un poil plus élevé
pourquoi processeur un poil plus rapide
et oui forcément il à diagonale d'écran
n'est pas la même non plus autant là
c'est du 6,43 autant la bastille du 6,6
on voyait déjà une différence qui est
important parce que même si vous me
direz on n'est pas sûr des différences
énormes mais pour voir qu'il a le même
nom est potentiellement la même
référence il ya déjà des différences
assez significative c'est pas juste le
processeur qui on va voir ici un corning
gorilla glass 3 pendant le protéger
l'ours n'est pas le dernier loin de là
mais bon il ya quand même une protection
qui est là why not des haut-parleurs
stéréo alors aller haut parleurs ça
serait sympa ce rendez vous mettre un
petit truc sur regarder on va avancer
c'est assez criard ça c'est megan ne
vous cache pas la regarder la leçon
c'est un leurre ça va défier l'autre
que mais bien uniquement dégage donc on
a un déséquilibre entre la droite qui va
être plus fort et la gauche alors ce que
je vous recommande surtout ne pas mettre
le son à fond parce que vous allez
vraiment vous arracher les oreilles vous
baisser un peu le sens de les récupérer
à un peu ingrat vendent pas énormément
mais un tout petit peu mais surtout vous
venez utilisé un petit casque en prise
jack c'est ce qui conviendra le mieux
après vous avez du bluetooth 5.0
convenir à péret des écouteurs sans
filet ce qui conviendra également alors
ça c'est un truc qui est intéressant
deuxième point qui est également
intéressant il ya une différence avec
l'autre modèle le modèle 5 g où vous
êtes du bluetooth
5.000 ce pas forcément changé grand
chose pour nous mais on voit une fois de
plus mais une différence quelle est la
vraie différence ça se fait à
l'intérieur au niveau du processeur
alors on va pas bien l'ouvrir et le
disséquer pour regarder ce qu'à
l'intérieur ici vous êtes chez mediatek
sur le 4g ou sur le 5 g ici c'est un et
lyon j'ai 96 processeurs 4g à la
différence du modèle 5g c'était un
dimanche city 810 on ira moins loin en
termes de performances on ne captera pas
la 5g parce que vous n'avez pas de modem
5 j'ai embarqué si vous avez de config
628 ou 8 256 tandis que sur l'autre
version vous aviez dû 4,64 et du 628
donc on peut aller un peu plus loin ici
au niveau de la ramée au niveau du
stockage les technos vous êtes vraiment
technophiles la ram c'est là ils
payèrent 4x et le stockage chez lui fs
2.21 grosse batterie de 5 millions
d'entrées alors ça ne change pas avec
leur recharge rapide regarder on l'a ici
c'est de la 33 watts donc ça c'est
plutôt bien ça va recharger rapidement
et vous savez je voulais déjà dit en
pleine vidéo mais ce côté il ya parce
que c'est un truc auquel je crois
énormément le fait d'avoir des blocs de
charge rapide ça vient effacer la
question de l'autonomie heures pour
autant on ne faut pas avoir un
smartphone que deux mais d'une
demi-journée sans quoi on va dire que
c'est vraiment naze et qu'on va passer
toutes les demies journal recharger non
on part sur des autonomies environ d'une
journée nuit c'est la moyenne si vous
jouez on sera en dessous si vous êtes à
la cool en sera un poil au dessus mais
pas énormément mais comme vous savez que
vous allez leur charge et très
rapidement en très peu de temps ont
regagné aller l'union et autonomie en
rechargeant assez rapidement on s'en
fiche de savoir si du une journée on est
en bas il ya vraiment un truc est
important avec cette augmentation de la
vitesse de charge et là on voit que ce
bloc directement de 33 watts et je
trouve ça plutôt bien alors côte
expérience logiciel ici on tourne sur me
why 13 pour pau qu on est un peu dans
l'idée de me why qu'on connaît de chez
chuo mine mais c'est l'expérience dédié
à pau qu avec une interface qui à ce que
leur cul pas mal c'est pas la plus sexy
du monde mais ça fonctionnera très très
bien on comprend rapidement ce qui se
passent vos différentes parties au
niveau de la collectivité au niveau de
l'écran au niveau de la sécurité
également donc là dessus j'ai absolument
rien à dire vous avez votre tiroir avec
vos applications et si vous pouvez
naviguer soit avec des boutons soit avec
des gestes comme vous le souhaitez bref
c'est clair c'est les ifs ça marche bien
et ça ça fonctionnera alors rien d'autre
qu'à voir c'est toute la partie photo
alors je vous le dis je vous le redis
vous le redis je vous montrerai
résultats dans quelques instants les
photos chez beaucoup c'est pas ça
pourquoi parce que ce n'est pas un
smartphone qui fait pour faire la photo
ça passe par google et pour faire la
photo pour faire des photos il pas du
tout optimisé non c'est plutôt un
smartphone qui va être optimisée pour la
performance pour le gaming et vous
proposer un smartphone de gaming
suffisamment musclée suffisamment
puissante suffisamment performants à
moindre coût regardez vous avez un
capteur principal history sur un 64
mégapixels s'écrit ici comme le port
salut au louvre à f 1.8 sur la version 5
g vous étiez 114,50 mégapixels ok bon
c'est pas le nombre de puits de sète qui
compte ça va être le capteur cet atelier
photos de sites et pas mal de choses
mais bon voilà ça il faut le savoir vous
avez également un second capteur c'est
un ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.2 avec un champ de vision
sans 18 degrés et puis vous avez de la
macro il voulons planqué justicier en
dessous et une fois de plus et capteur
micro c'est vraiment histoire de se
marrer c'est un capteur de 2 mégapixels
qui on rêve 2.4 bon voilà si vous avez
vraiment envie de faire la macro mais
sinon globalement croyez-moi ça sert pas
à grand chose mais même les résultats
macro et d'un homme on regarde ça juste
après et puis vous avez une caméra de
celles fixées planque hélas au milieu
pas vraiment planqué notre qu'en plein
milieu vous la voyez c'est une 16
mégapixels tour f 2.4 donc voyons un
taux qui est très très très classique
aussi au niveau de la photo et de la
vidéo côté vidéo pourrait bien filmé
jusqu'en 1080p à 30 fps voyez c'est pas
énorme pas vraiment venir faire des
trucs de dingue donc on sait pas du tout
un smartphone qui est fait pour la vidéo
la photo c'est l'expérience me why 13
pour poko donc bon rennes à vous
apprendre de bien dingo là dessus ça
fonctionnera le mode portrait les modes
plus on va éviter de faire n'importe
quoi mot de professionnels mais très
clairement ici on va pas non plus venir
s'amuser à faire des photos en mode pro
avec ce smartphone là les gens mal
automatique si vous arrivez à faire des
bons clichés ce sera déjà très très bien
je monte rapidement quelques photos que
j'ai fait avec mon pot coësmes quatre
pros alors son capteur principal on
arrivera à sortir des choses c'est très
classique ce que je vous dis ah mais
c'est tellement vrai on arrive à faire
des choses sur l'ultra grand temps qu'on
perd largement précision il faut
beaucoup de lumière et on va pas venir
tout mais je vous ai fait un x de lavery
déjà c'est pas extraordinaire sur le
côté ombre sur le côté ils sont philippe
katerine c'est pas dingue sur la colo a
c'est pareil là haut niveau là où il
écrit balard bon voilà c'est pas fait
pour ça une autre en plein jour avec
beaucoup de soleil ça marche bien c'est
convenable c'est assez convenable et ça
va alors c'est pas la voir les photos
les plus contrastées c'est avoir le
meilleur résultat mais le résultat est
convenable ultra-grand-angle avec
beaucoup de lumière il n'a pas trop mal
alors bon la colorimétrie va pas être
extraordinaire c'est pas parfait c'est
un peu moins bien voyez notamment aussi
au niveau du bâtiment mais pour des
souvenirs ça va c'est pas mal x 2 c'est
pareil real et on a vraiment de
l'imprécision aussi ce qu'on n'a pas été
réactif ont bien joué mais directement
dans l'image numérique et c'est pas
parfait rader pareils capteur principal
sa fuite afin nettement sa foi le taf
pour le reste c'est la même chose pas
ici on va qu'on a au niveau de lumière
ça fonctionne à peu près attention de la
limite mais ça va là par contre sur
l'ultra grand temps il ôte lumière c'est
pas terrible à radés sur les volets
c'est si on fait trop ils n'arrivent pas
s'est passé pas ouf là il ya une vraie
des formations elles vont au niveau du
bâti en même temps que ça c'est un monde
sur le côté et c'est pareil on peut
zoomer un peu de monde à éviter toujours
un peu la même chose a retenu zoomer
davantage on paye ce camp x 17 x 6 x 8 x
10 voyez on n'y va pas franchement on
n'y va pas et pareil là alors au niveau
des hautes lumières il a eu plus de mal
ce n'est vraiment chercher quelque chose
avec des hautes lumières qu'ils se
calment ça marche plus trop même
critique ici sur l' ultra grand-angle
tadla précision s'ébruiter sur le côté
le résultat il est pas beau du tout
pareil voyez on ne sait pas où la caméra
de cette fille c'est pas beau très
honnêtement je vous le dis les
traitements sur la peau ne sont pas
beaux d'un côté ou de l'autre vraiment
c'est pas beau du tout lors la macro
n'en parlons même pas je vois même pas
pourquoi nommer de la macro sur ses
smartphones il faut mettre des capteurs
pour mettre des capteurs c'est une
notion de marketing mais dans les faits
ce que vous allez sortir ici en macro
n'est pas dingue donc ce qu'on retient
ici c'est que le capteur principal frale
tafer sera très correctes très
honnêtement que vu le positionnement
tarifaire lutte rag entendre on peut en
faire des choses si vraiment on le veut
mais il faut beaucoup de lumière ce que
c'est pas ouf quand même c'est un peu
d'effort mans il ya du bruit on peut
venir ou n'en faut 2 mais voilà
franchement faut-il non je ne pense pas
vaut mieux venir vous rapprocher de
votre smartphone pour éviter de dégrader
les qualités et la macro bain on n'y va
pas mais bon allez là donc bon et puis
c'est un smartphone qui est certifié ip
53 qu'il y à du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé qui est proposé à un tarif
de hawaï pas se regarder et on parle du
tarif café coule la feuille ça fait
toujours plaisir 628 ses 229 euros et 8
256 279 euros alors bon ok why not samba
plutôt bien mais c'est marrant parce
qu'ils ont redescendu les tarifs du
m4 pro 5 g qui était sur la version 4,64
à 200 quasiment 230 euros c'est à dire
le prix de la version 628 à celle à 5 g
un autre modèle c'est un autre procès
intérieur et vous aviez une version 628
qui elle est tournée à 239 euros donc
elle va être un peu plus cher que la
version 628 ici mais vous avez un
processeur plus performant vous avez un
modem 5 g vous avez un smartphone qui
aura un poil plus loin qu'à questions
diverses posées ici si vous hésitez à
savoir entreprendre lepoko m44 gilles
pourquoi me 4,5 g la première vraie
question bien poser c'est est ce que
j'ai un abonnement 5 j ai ce que je
compte prendre l'abonnement 5g dans les
deux à trois ans à venir c'est la durée
de vie de smartphones brienne évidemment
est ce qu'il ya un intérêt pour vous il
ya toujours la question du prix est bien
évidemment la version 4g sera moins cher
que la version 5 j'aime parce que
j'avoue recommandé ici c'est le 628 à
229 euros c'est très canon au niveau du
tarif vous avez en plus des offres
intéressantes en ce moment lorsqu'il est
lancé je vous mets le lien en bas à
description à l'extérieur ça peut être
intéressant pour vous je trouve pas mal
comme ça donc c'est à vous de voir un
peu comment vous vous situez par rapport
à ça bien évidemment que le modèle 5g
vous aurez un poil plus de performance
ne vous attendez pas à faire tourner les
jeux les plus complexes les jeux les
plus fous les jeux qui nécessitent le
plus de performances là dessus vous
allez faire tourner plein de jeux
beaucoup de jeux voyez moi je peux faire
tourner allez on va se mettre qu'on va
se fait un petit jeu histoire de se
marrer renvoyer c'est pas le jeu le plus
dingue que je vous félicite c'est un as
page 9 mai dans l'idée d'avoir un jeu
qui fonctionne qui est pour tous ont
suffisamment fluide pour avoir une bonne
expérience ici là vous avez un tout qui
conviendra alors on va éviter jeudi ils
passent plus les jeux les plus gourmands
mais c'est vraiment l'idée de
smartphones c'est de l'expérience sur
mobile avec des jeux pas les plus
gourmands on va pas avoir le truc le
plus faux faux faux
et malgré tout on va vers la la ça pète
de la bagnole ça fait de la bagnole avec
ça c'est n'importe quoi voilà donc on
fait tourner plein de jeux comme ça ça
convient on se fait plaisir on sait news
je sais pas si vous entendez là mais je
vais tous elles sont un peu plus forts
ça arrache un peu les gens rien tout à
l'heure j'ai joué quand j'ai arrêté ça
fait vraiment y faire mal aux oreilles
comme je baisse parce que je vous assure
que ça a vraiment et voilà 12e olala
j'ai trop parlé chenal le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que voyez plein de
petits jeux comme ça vous allez pouvoir
les faire tourner et vous allez pouvoir
jouer c'est vraiment ce qu'on va retenir
ici un grand écran un smartphone qui est
fait pour le gaming sans en faire trop
un smartphone équilibre est qu une
grosse batterie se retrouvent de la
recharge rapide c'est vraiment l'adn de
ce poème quatre pros je le trouve plutôt
pas mal dans cette gamme de prix
conviendra puis une fois de plus les
tarifs sont assez agressif ici bas vous
ce que vous en pensez on va en
commentaire est ce que vous avez déjà
acheté un smartphone peut qu est ce que
c est le cas de propos vous faire de
l'oeil à ce qu'ils peuvent ou tenter oui
donc comment vous marquez de sa fille se
retrouve bientôt pour continuer à parler
de poko des chiots me parce qu'à plein
de modèles ils ont donc tout le temps
toute l'année si c'était le père noël il
sera toute l'année on aurait madre par
nous à tout jamais alors j'en ai pas
marre de marcher mais toute l'année mais
ils sont là toute l'année avec des
produits de ces dingues une vraie la
grippe alors on en parle mais trop
d'embarras
[Musique]